[Musica]
[Applauso]
che cosa ci spinge ad imparare
io mi sono fatto questa domanda molto
spesso
me lo chiedevo sempre quando mi sentivo
dire è bravo ma non si applica
quanti di voi si sono sentiti dire bravo
ma non si applica
beh sono in buona compagnia
ricordo ancora le parole della
professoressa d'inglese del liceo una
donna tutta d'un pezzo con accento
british anche quando parlavano italiano
impegnati un giorno inglese ti servirà è
fondamentale per il mondo del lavoro
ma lo stimolo non arrivava
e io preferivo passare i miei pomeriggi
a fare qualche videogioco strano
piuttosto che studiare
ovviamente per la fine del liceo il mio
livello di inglese era semplicemente
pessimo
poi iniziò le università mi trovo in un
ambiente internazionale e per paura di
sentirmi escluso iniziano le prime
incertezze
forse la professoressa del liceo aveva
ragione
decido quindi di rischiare
inizia a cercare un opportunità di
lavoro all'estero e nel giro di qualche
settimana se una banca in canada a fare
uno stage durante le olimpiadi invernali
questo sono io ero più giovane
sicuramente più elegante ma il mio
livello di inglese era ancora pessimo
e all'inizio stato sfidante
avevo paura di parlare
facevo fatica da prendere e questo mi ha
messo in uno stato di crisi uno stato di
crisi interno
quando provavo a parlare
facevo fatica quando mi parlavano facevo
finta di capire ma in realtà non capivo
poi ho pensato
sono a 10 mila chilometri di distanza da
casa
in un posto incredibile con della gente
pazzesca di cosa dovrei aver paura
ed ecco che scatta qualcosa questa paura
si trasforma e sfida
una sfida proprio come quelle dei
videogiochi che mi piacevano tanto e nel
giro di qualche giorno mi rendo conto
che il processo di apprendimento sarà
tutta in discesa
inizio perfino a sognare in inglese la
dimostrazione che mi ero sbloccato
concludo il mio percorso di studi
universitari scrivendo e discutendo la
tesi in inglese alla fine mi ero
applicato
ma perché non mi sono applicato prima
è possibile che in scenari di incertezza
abbiamo maggiori incentivi ad imparare
questa domanda per me è diventata quasi
un'ossessione
e da questa ossessione
sei anni fa insieme a degli amici
abbiamo creato una scuola online
l'obiettivo era semplice e ambizioso
creare una scuola di competenze digitali
che incentivasse l'apprendimento
questi siamo noi a berlino nella mia
cameretta mentre stiamo creando le
fondamenta di questa scuola
sei anni dopo abbiamo più di 80.000
studenti e ogni giorno ci impegniamo a
migliorare a fare formazione
recentemente ho trovato uno studio
dell'università di yale
questo studio di neuroscienza dimostra
che abbiamo una maggiore attività
cerebrale
quando siamo in un contesto di
incertezza mentre abbiamo minore
attività cerebrale quando la situazione
è semplice da prevedere
la conferma quindi mi arriva proprio
dalla scienza della neuroscienza e
nell'incertezza che abbiamo maggiori
incentivi ad imparare e tutti noi ci
troviamo ad imparare nella nostra vita a
volte lo facciamo più volte nel corso di
una vita lo facciamo perché ci obbligano
lo facciamo perché vogliamo migliorare o
crescere nel nostro lavoro
lo facciamo perché siamo curiosi
e abbiamo tantissimi incentivi nel
nell'imparare e io ho notato una cosa
quando impariamo seguiamo tutti un
percorso simile simile a tutti noi l'ho
provato in primis sulla mia pelle
e l'ho scoperto anche dall'esperienza
dei nostri studenti
questo processo è composto da tre fasi
fase 1 la scintilla
in questa fase siamo in un contesto di
incertezza incertezza interna siamo
insicuri vogliamo imparare qualcosa
siamo curiosi
oppure da un'incertezza esterna
l'ambiente che ci circonda
l'ecosistema ci spingono a voler
imparare qualcosa di nuovo
perché la scintilla è proprio questo è
un incentivo che ci fa scattare un
desiderio il desiderio di imparare
imparare una nuova competenza
e successo anche a me io lavoravo in una
banca di investimento e lavoro mi
piaceva era il percorso perfetto per la
mia carriera
ma sentivo la necessità il bisogno di un
nuovo stimolo però anche molto
appassionato dal mondo digitale
ed ecco che arriva la mia scintilla john
il mio amico john
il mio amico john mi incuriosisce
parlandomi di programmazione
ormai sono incuriosito mi vedo già come
un programmatore
ed ecco che sono nella fase ii fase due
la ricerca in questa fase ormai siamo
incuriositi sappiamo che vogliamo
imparare qualcosa di nuovo e si attiva
il nostro lato nerd andiamo su google
scriviamo come imparare a
iniziamo a leggere dei libri iniziamo a
studiare anche io l'ho fatto ho iniziato
a visitare i blog
vedere centinaia di video online
ne ho perfino visto uno di 28 minuti che
paragonavano in cui si paragonava
l'evoluzione dei linguaggi di
programmazione all'evoluzione della
specie umana
sì ero curioso in questa fase siamo
curiosi in siamo pieni di energia stiamo
imparando apprendiamo concetti nuovi
e siamo motivati
tutto sembra andare per il verso giusto
ma ecco che arriva alla fase 3
crisi
questa fase abbiamo le prime difficoltà
soprattutto avviene quando iniziamo a
mettere in pratica quello che stiamo
imparando
iniziamo avere i primi dubbi e questi
dubbi fanno scattare in noi lo stato di
crisi nello stato di crisi interno
questo stato di crisi ci porta ad avere
paura paura di sbagliare
ci sono passato anch'io
ho pensato stavo imparando a programmare
prima difficoltà cosa ho pensato
forse non fa per me
quante volte nella vita pensiamo forse
non fa per me ci passano tutti ci
passano anche i nostri studenti e lo
vediamo spesso anche su di loro
passiamo tutti da questo stato di crisi
crisi
dal greco
significa scelta decisione infatti il
successo della nostra esperienza di
apprendimento è dato proprio dalla
scelta di come decidiamo di approcciare
questa fase
e io come l'ho bruciata come quando ho
imparato inglese ma se non trovare una
trovata una sfida una sfida come quella
dei videogiochi che mi piacevano tanto
al liceo quando non volevo studiare
ho deciso di realizzare il sito di un
ristorante in cambio di qualche cena
nel giro di una settimana
qualche notte insonne
il sito è online
e anche se non sembra da questo ed era
perfetto
ok no non era perfetto era pieno di bug
dal telefono si leggeva male ed era
perfino lento a caricarsi ma per me era
perfetto perché mi aveva dimostrato che
potevo diventare un programmatore
e questo processo lo vediamo spesso
anche se i nostri studenti
ad esempio cerchiamo di incentivarli a
mettere in pratica subito quello che
stanno imparando
a non aver paura di sbagliare
buttati
mettiti in gioco
scopri tuo stato di crisi questo è
quello che cerchiamo di passare
in questo processo di apprendimento
funziona quando vogliamo imparare delle
nuove competenze
e se ci pensate bene
crescere
non è un percorso di apprendimento
continuo
un'immagine di questo processo di
crescita
potrebbe essere questa
quelli invece siamo noi
la bandierina il nostro obiettivo e
quelli in alto solitamente quello che ci
immaginiamo quello che vorremmo che sia
il nostro processo di crescita abbiamo
un obiettivo cerchiamo di raggiungerlo
maniera lineare
cresciamo in maniera piuttosto
prevedibile
la realtà però siamo né grafico sotto
provate a pensare quando aveva appunto
imparato qualcosa di nuovo alla
relazione con un vostro partner con
degli amici o quando vi siete anche a
portare ad uno sport
probabilmente non è stato un processo di
crescita lineare e stato un processo
fatto di alti e bassi come delle
montagne russe proprio come grafico
sotto
e sapete cosa mi ricorda
mi ricorda uno di quei videogiochi che
mi piaceva tantissimo quando ero
ragazzino quando ero al liceo e non
volevo studiare
io non avrei mai giocato a quello sopra
noioso poco sfidante nessuno vorrebbe
farlo quello sotto invece sembra
divertente sfidante bisogna attraversare
dei massi attraversare un ponte che
rischia di crollare
costruirsi una barca imparare a navigare
superare una tempesta e forza arrivare
alla bandierina questo è sfidante
e la vita se ci pensate bene e questo è
un processo di crescita dove abbiamo
delle difficoltà
delle sfide
e delle crisi
ma possiamo eliminare le crisi
conoscete la storia del cigno nero
il cigno nero
fino al 1700 nell'emisfero dove siamo
noi quello quello boreale si credeva che
il cigno nero non esistesse
poi si scopre l'australia è un
esploratore olandese durante una delle
sue esplorazioni vede per la prima volta
un cigno nero ce n'era esiste
questo ci dimostra che quello che
crediamo sia impossibile in realtà può
essere smentito successivamente
il cigno nero è diventato una metafora
per indicare un evento che è difficile
da prevedere
ha effetti rilevanti
e può essere razionalizzato a posteriori
e le crisi ad oggi
utilizzano la metafora del cigno nero
quando vogliamo parlare di una crisi
diciamo che un cigno nero proprio perché
è difficile da prevedere
ha un impatto
ea posteriori viene razionalizzata
la storia del cigno nero ci insegna che
le crisi esistono e sono una parte
integrante della nostra vita
e invece di eliminarle dovremmo provare
a vederle come delle sfide
delle sfide che ci danno l'opportunità
di crescere delle sfide dove questi
momenti di difficoltà possono diventare
delle occasioni di crescita e di
apprendimento
quindi
per tornare alla domanda iniziale
che cosa ci spinge ad imparare
tutto parte da una scintilla
che ci spinge alla ricerca
ma il vero momento che ci porta a
crescere e la crisi
infatti
e nell incertezza
che l'incertezza che ci spinge ad
imparare
ma è la crisi che stimola il nostro
cervello ad apprendere realmente
quale prossima crisi può diventare la
tua opportunità di crescita
[Applauso]